c'est une mère effondrée qui depuis deux
mois retourne sans cesse la même
question comment peut-on mourir à 15 ans
fauché par une balle a Besançon
Abdelmalek était à l'aube de sa vie
celui que tout le monde a plaisir était
connu pour ses blagues son humour et son
maître 90
chaque matin il descend des escaliers
il me voit faire quelque chose il prend
de Mama et je mordille fois par jour
si cette maman parle aujourd'hui c'est
pour faire taire les rumeurs qui
présente son fils comme un dealer ce 29
août Abdelmalek partait en réalité pour
un match de foot avec son ballon sur son
trajet ce point de Deal bien connu du
quartier de Planoise
cette photo prise par les habitants
juste après les coups de feu et
transmise à la famille semble conforter
la thèse de la maman mais c'est une
balle perdue ils disent comme ça une
dame qui habite là-bas elle m'a dit
jamais j'ai vu ton fils ici et je vous
cache pas j'ai parti voir les douleurs
là-bas les githers là-bas j'ai posé des
questions
jamais on l'a vu ici un adolescent au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment les
soutiens de la famille dénoncent
l'omerta qui règne depuis deux mois
dans les personnes qui habitent
directement ils sont très très bien le
qui a fait ça mais jamais personne ne
dira quoi que ce soit du silence parce
que il y a des peurs de représailles ce
qui est légitime parce que là c'est pas
des petits délinquants on peut voir avec
avec ce qu'ils font ils sont armés ils
ont des armes de des armes de guerre
Abdelmalek était le dernier de cinq
enfants il voulait se lancer dans un CAP
en pâtisserie demain sa maman sera
présente lors de la Marche Blanche en sa
mémoire et j'espère que la justice font
leur travail
je te montre que ça mais je veux pas
pour lui
il faut il faut